voters have set the stage for three  pivotal Senate races in November with  Republicans battling to keep control  West Virginia Republicans rejected Don  Blankenship in one of the most closely  watched primaries the former coal  executive and ex-con but a controversial  racially charged campaign State Attorney  General Patrick Morrissey won that race  and he'll face off with Democratic  incumbent Joe Manchin in November in  Ohio GOP congressman Jim Rene si will  take on Democratic senator sherrod Brown  and businessman Mike Braun will run  against Indiana Senator Joe Donnelly  right now the GOP holds a 51 to 49  Senate majority